[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle a le regard qui tue elle a dû la
première
m'a touché ses foutu vous connaissez
tous la blague du pingouin qui respire
par l'anus un jour il s'assoit et il
meurt évidemment et bien sachez qu'on
aurait pu faire cette blague avec le
concombre de mer car lui respire bel et
bien par son derrière j'avais
l'impression d'être Céline Dion
j'adore ce genre de réponse vous vous
étiez qui Léa
[Applaudissements]
je me suis dit oh merde
deux influenceurs tu vois c'est pas du
tout mon truc et tout tu vois donc puis
après tu sais comme je me suis dit je
suis assez curieuse je me suis dit
laisse-toi faire et en plus quand tu
m'as dit que vous étiez pas youtubeur
mais que vous faisiez du rap je me suis
dit c'est pire encore
ma nature à ce stade ce serait de leur
dire bravo parce que le tableau est
magnifique est très bonne la vérité
quand même c'est que on n'est pas encore
au niveau de Céline Dion Lara Fabian et
Beyoncé retour à la réalité ça s'appelle
mais oui on peut rêver on a le droit on
est là pour ça il pompe l'eau de mer par
le rectum et non par sa bouche l'oxygène
contenu dans l'eau est alors transférée
de l'anus au système respiratoire
interne qui redirige ensuite l'oxygène
dans son organisme et ainsi respire-t-il
regardez comme une inspire profondément
et il expire il inspire et il est je
crois qu'il a roté
je suis en train de faire pareil Stan
tant mieux revoilà le concours de la
photo animalière la plus amusante de
l'année c'est aux internautes de
départager les 40 finalistes entre les
vautours impudiques les manchots en
froid les chutes en pagaille et les
illusions d'optique difficile de faire
un choix il y aura forcément des déçus
le grand vainqueur sera annoncé le 8
décembre
est-ce que tu as un message quand même
pour les gens qui ont voté pour toi ce
soir merci
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup c'est un honneur et je suis
arrivé d'avoir pu conquis le public
vraiment enfin de troisième plus d'un
tiers des élèves se sont découragés
quand on leur demande de lire un texte
d'une simple page des difficultés de
lecture donc mais aussi de compréhension
puisque 30% déclarent également de voir
relire le texte en entier pour répondre
à chaque question un niveau de lecture
en baisse au collège du selon les
spécialistes à la diminution du volume
d'heures de français depuis des années
qui s'appelle la Villa Benny vidi vici
quoi ça veut dire je suis venu manger je
suis venu j'ai je suis resté dans le
genre exactement bah en gros c'est
quasiment pas
positivement
je commence à
je commence à l'entrée aperçoit un peu
plus sur le direct merci
vous avez gagné aucun de vos deux l non
non je suis je suis très mauvais pour
baiser pour baiser pour baiser
[Applaudissements]
Tom a dit je suis très mauvais pour
buzzer tout à fait rapport aux buzzer si
vous avez entendu quelque chose c'est un
problème de votre téléviseur alors
natalité Enzo la définition le coût de
la panne la fait croire la panne de
pilule peut-être non à la panne de
pilule non c'est pas du tout ça c'est la
panne d'électricité
vous savez on prétexte une panne
d'électricité bon c'est pas quoi faire
et bah dit bam natalité
très bien alors on en avait pas encore
parlé Enzo
indien c'est là j'étais devant lui et
tout mais c'était génial ton beau
chamanique et il ouvre les yeux je vous
jure que c'est vrai il ouvre les yeux
comme ça il me fait vous êtes cougar
à mon mari il va être le frère insulte
Charlotte de loin avant de prendre la
fuite
j'ai 58 ans on dit si à 50 ans
c'est pareil
[Musique]
et toujours autant carbo Joe Biden
toujours pas compris où se trouvait la
sortie de la scène
[Musique]
êtes-vous un homme pressé
parce que je suis un homme pressé
pas là apparemment